[Music]
let's go to kathleen in macon georgia
we're not gonna we're not gonna cheer
things up are we
kathleen you there
hey i'm here all right kathleen what's
up
hey dr john
how are you
i'm okay how about you
it doesn't sound okay let's get into it
what's up
um
so
um
i was just calling in because um
i was trying to figure out
you seem real nervous are you okay
for now
okay don't be nervous i'm nervous too
and listen you've heard this show i'm
not great at this and so i i'm setting
the bar really low for both of us so
you're good so what's up
okay so i guess about
hey you're him hauling around just jump
on in you called like we're in it
just pretend me and you're sitting at a
coffee shop what happened
okay so a quick rundown a couple of
months ago our guest back in march or
whatever um
it started back in march um
i changed jobs or whatever and um
i had ended up getting involved
emotionally with
a co-worker okay and i
found out about it and um your husband
found out about it
yes okay so when you say you got
involved emotionally with a co-worker
what does that mean
well i didn't realize that at the time
until afterwards so i like started
researching or whatever and um
you're so around the issues tell me
directly what happened
were y'all texting each other that i
love you and i miss you and started
making plans were you sitting each other
like
like nude photos of each other like tell
me what emotional affair looks like
everything but y'all just didn't hook up
in a hotel like what what was going on
we like talked
a lot texted um
he told me things about his
um relationship his wife
um i've told him things about my
marriage and intimate things that
shouldn't have been
like
talked about outside of marriage
um
i don't know he would and we texted like
a lot okay
um it was never anything
i mean it was inappropriate to me
okay
um
he was
superior to me so i mean he was my boss
okay
so as far as like texting so your
husband finds out about so
backing out you never slept with him
right
no never held hands never kissed him
never
like never okay so
in your head you've called this an
emotional affair but you know you
crossed the lines that you shouldn't
have that's where we're at right
yeah okay and then your husband found
out
and then what happened
so
well right before this happened a couple
weeks before this happened um
we were already kind of like
disconnected or whatever of course yeah
they kind of talking and this was
already kind of happening before i
changed jobs um
back in march
and my husband kind of came to me one
day i could say where he's like went in
top and he's like well i gotta know
what's going on
and i kind of brushed off and he told me
about some issues that you know he was
going through and
he's like you know i really want to work
on our marriage like i do too a lot and
um
so
but i didn't tell him about the
relationship or whatever okay
that i had at work
and because i guess i thought i could
end it on my own that's what i was
thinking in my head okay yeah
then a couple of weeks after that that's
when he found out
i was deleting text messages
and um but i wasn't i guess it wasn't
deleting fast enough on my watch or
whatever and that's how i found out
about the messages okay
so then so you
cross some lines
in your heart and in your head and
then you lie to your husband about it
and yeah your marriage was already messy
and um he had been vulnerable with you
and said hey i really want to work on
this and you said me too
and
but yeah that would have been the moment
to say hey
i'm
i'm not doing well either
and you didn't you kept that quiet and
then he discovers this on his own and
now what does he want to be done this
whole thing
yeah because well back in the past like
even before all this happened i had like
an issue
where like i
racked up like a ton of like credit card
debt and i ended up coming claim about
that a couple of years ago
and anyways we're working on that
and we're getting that all you know
figured out and paying all our debt down
or whatever
and but you have a history in this
relationship of being dishonest with
your husband
yeah
yeah
so how can i help you
he has this thing about trust
most of us do just fyi
like man my husband's so weird he's got
this thing about trust all of us do
really
so like
do you struggle with taking
responsibility for stuff
well no i take responsibility because
i'm angry at myself that i do this to my
husband
but like
every day like you know he's always
questioning like he's he
still thinks like we we just you know
more he still thinks every day did you
have sex he just i said no we did not we
did not do anything
of course he's going to because you've
got a history of lying to him
and that's why my real question was like
how do i earn trust or whatever with him
and i just even like i'm 100 honest now
like
he knows everything like he knows all
about over our finances
he looks at my phone all the time
there's i don't ever close out of apps i
don't delete anything i know but you're
you're
you heal from this
you heal from this type of trust you
quit your job you said
yeah i quit my job okay
you heal from this type of
um
dishonesty slowly and over time
and
he has to decide
he's gonna have to decide to be
vulnerable and be willing to be lied to
and hurt again
and
it's gonna take a long time
my guess is you also are dishonest about
other things
and that these are two big ones because
you got really busted right
um
but there's other things too
and there's little this is and that's
and how many drinks did you have i just
had one but i had four
or
did you call that guy no
and and and
back when y'all were dating have you
have you ever cheated on him before
no
no marshall sweetheart okay
um
yeah the
your relationship's not doing great
and what have you all gone to see
somebody
no i asked him to but he won't okay
um
you need to go
for you
you pay you need to go for you that's
all you can do you can't force him to do
anything
and um he's been burned again and again
and again and again
and he's probably not a saint in this
deal right he's probably not
um
but he
you have not given him a reason to trust
okay and so what you have to
do is go start working on you number one
get to the bottom of what are you
bringing to this relationship that's
making it dysfunctional it's making it
not
healthy and that's beyond
getting involved emotionally with a
co-worker okay that stuff happens you
get great friendships that turn into
great relationships that turn into is
your wife like this is your husband like
this and suddenly you're like whoa what
happened what happened and um
so that happens
and then there's a line right and then
there's a sneaking around and then
there's the secrets then there's the it
just kind of gets out of control right i
don't i'm not pissed off at you for that
it happens
i'm i'm not pissed off at you for
anything actually um
but those things happen it's when you
got to flip the lights on and say whoa
where are we
right and then you've got a pattern of
this stuff that says that there's some
cracks in the foundation of your
relationship do you want to stay married
to this guy
yes
beyond
beyond just wanting to stay married do
you want to have a good relationship
yes
what does that even look like for you
a lot of honesty
talking on time communicating
beyond that bigger than that what does
it even mean
i don't think you have a good picture of
what that means
and what a counselor is going to help
you do is decide these magic words what
do you want
yeah and i don't think you can answer
that question
fully i think you can answer what you
don't want which is you don't want to be
single you don't want the guy to leave
you
you now realize oh crap this all can go
away
right i think you know what you don't
want but i don't think you know what you
actually want probably professionally do
you have kids
yeah how many
two two how old are they
um one's about to be six and the other
one is three yeah you're right in the
middle of this
um is a hard season for couples every
couple i know has hard seasons with
little kids like this
um
but i don't it just becomes a mess
especially for a professional woman
who's trying to be a mom trying to be
all this is a mess and i think you got
to go sit somebody i would be great if
he came with you but if he won't he
won't right he won't he won't you got to
go deal with you
and so i want you to call somebody today
i've got a if you don't have a counselor
in your area which you do
um you can call betterhelp.com they'll
give you a discount you can join on that
i got a partnership with them you have
no excuses you can do it online i'd
rather you go in person right now
because this thing's a mess
and let him know i screwed up and
you can continue to look at anything
i've got i'm going to go take care of
myself
i haven't been who i want to be in this
thing
life is nuts with two little kids life
is like i had to quit my job all this
stuff i just need to get things
straightened down i'd love for you to
come with me and
you cannot talk your way into him
trusting you again that's gone
you've got a show
and not performative not look look look
look but i love you i'm gonna keep
showing up i'm gonna keep showing up i'm
gonna keep showing up and i'm gonna
start working on me
so thanks for that call kathleen that's
hard man that's hard
it's hard i'd love to talk to him have
him give me a call i'd love to hear his
side of this thing too i'd love love
love to chat with him
sorry there's not like a silver lining
on this one right now um this is just
mess um actually you know what there is
a silver lining on it which is going to
take a lot of work a lot of intentional
work and a lot of kathleen going first
right